hello everybody welcome to the tutorial
which is a memory card game built in
pure JavaScript so to follow this
tutorial you don't have to know a lot
just the basics of HTML CSS and GS like
basic tags basic CSS selectors and
what's a function
you can find the files for each video at
github comm slash called sketch in a
written tutorial in the game demo at
Medina slash fajita dot github.com so if
you got lost along the way please refer
to those ok let's get started
we are gonna start with the basic file
structure so in our terminal let's make
a directory called memory game let's
change directory into that new directory
to create the files we're gonna touch
index dot HTML styles dot CSS and
scripts yes we are also going to make a
directory called MiG for our images so
in the editor let's open our index dot
HTML
and declare our file as an html5
document with doctype in the root tag
let's specify the language as English
and inside the head tag that set our
character encoding to utf-8 set the
title to memory game and Link the
stylesheet
and inside our body tag we are going to
add this script
in style.css we are going to add a reset
to all items by setting padding to zero
margin to zero and box-sizing to border
box
the box size improperly handles how
padding in border will be added to an
element the default value for box sizing
is content box which means that any
border are padding applied to the
element will add to its total width and
height the other options border box
which adds padding and border to the
element without changing its dimensions
so it shrinks the available space for
the content keeping its original size
one thing to keep in mind
box-sizing does not apply to margin okay
either option you choose margin will
never be accounted as elements
dimensions let's set the body height to
a hundred pH so V H stands for viewport
height and viewport is the visible area
of your webpage so the unit VH
corresponds to one percent of the
viewport height by setting it to 100 our
body will take a hundred percent of the
available height space and finally let's
set the background color
our board will be composed of a
container div called memory game and by
12 cards each card consists of a memory
card div that holds two images one
representing the cards back face and the
other representing its front face
so back in the editor let's make that
into HTML
to download the images please visit the
project repo at github
you
so now that we have added all the
elements let's also add a temporary
width of a hundred pixels to all images
so we can have a better idea of what's
going on
you
in style.css we're going to be styling
our memory game game container and the
memory card front face and back face
elements so let's add a border to each
one of them so you can better visualize
them
let's remove that temporary image width
and let's add a 640 pixel width and
height to our container
you
let's also set display to flex so what's
going on here is that when we apply
display flex to a container we kind of
get some other property set for us by
default so what does properties tell our
items is each one of you will take the
same amount of space in the screen into
the container it says your items should
be laid out in a row in just one row and
they're going to be positioned from left
to right and there will be stretched out
across the containers height our board
has three rows for card speech so let's
apply to the memory card a 25% width and
at 3333
% height
well we can see that the height is being
correctly applied but the width is not
so remember when I said that we had some
default properties in the Flex container
one of them is flex wrap which is set to
no wrap and is preventing the items from
being laid out across multiple rows so
let's reset it to wrap now we have to
position the front face and the back
face on top of each other so let's add a
position:absolute to them and well this
is not what we wanted at all so let's
take a closer look here when you add
position:absolute on element the element
has to find out relative to what am I
gonna position myself it doesn't know so
it asks its parent in which in this case
is box 3 so he goes
box 3 are you positioned in the an
element is only positioned to the screen
if it has a position relative set box 3
does not have that so it answers no I'm
not positioned the element then goes
okay not a problem
I'm gonna ask your parent box - are you
positioned box 2 is gonna go no I'm not
positioned okay I'll ask your parent box
1 are you positioned box one's gonna go
no I'm not
then the element says since none of you
is positioned I'm gonna position myself
relative to the body and this is why
right now the element is sitting at the
top left corner if we apply position
relative to the box 1 when the element
asks box 1 are you positioned box one
box one's gonna go yes I am positioned
the element says qu then I'm gonna
position myself relative to you and the
same goes if we apply position relative
to box 2 and 3 which means that an
element with
absolute positions itself relative to
the nearest positioned ancestor back in
our template what's going on here is
that since none of our elements are
positioned to the screen front face and
back face are positioning themselves
relative to the body and we want them to
be positioned relative to the memory
card so let's add a position relative to
it
let's make the images take the whole
width and height of its container and
let's also apply some padding border
radius and background color let's remove
the borders and apply a 5 pixel margin
to our memory card
the layout has broken because the margin
makes our cards overflow the available
space okay so on calculating our width
and height we have to take that margin
under consideration the CSS calc
function allows us to subtract the
margin value from the width and height
so let's apply that
for centering the memory game container
we are going to apply a display flex to
the body and margin Auto to the memory
game and that's going to Center it
vertically and horizontally
you
let's set a click effect to the memory
card so the active pseudo class is going
to be triggered whenever an element gets
clicked so we're going to apply a
transform scale of nine ninety seven
percent of its original size
let's make that a bit smoother by
applying a transition to it
and for that transition to work we have
to have a starting place so let's apply
transforms ko1 to the memory card
there's a typo here
and there you go
so now let's make the card flip when we
click it the first thing you have to do
is to make a list of all memory card
elements and store it inside a constant
named cards to do that we are going to
use document dot carry selector all
passing the memory card class so then we
are going to loop through that list into
each one of the cards we are going to
attach an event listener we are going to
listen for a click event and whenever
that event is fired we are going to
execute a function named flip card
let's declare the Flipkart function and
let's log a message to see if it's
working and let's also see what's inside
that this keyword okay because this
value is dynamically set according to
the context so let's see in this context
what our this keyword represents
so you can see our functions being cold
and inside the dis variable we can see
that we have our memory card so in this
context that this keyword represents the
element that fired the event okay
so what we want here is to I access the
class list of the memory card and to
toggle the flipped class what toggle
means is if the class is there remove it
if it's not added
okay so let's navigate to our elements
tab and we can say that it's toggling
the class
so back in Styles dot CSS let's set that
flip class so we want to select the
memory card element that also has a flip
class remember that there is no space
between the names because the two
classes belong to the same element okay
so when the flip class is present we are
gonna rotate the y-axis 180 degrees
let's add a 3d effect to the card
flipping so the perspective property is
what's gonna give some depth to our
elements okay so we're gonna add a 1000
pixel perspective to the memory game
container and also a property that's
called transform style preserve 3d to
the memory card because that's what's
gonna insert our memory card element
inside the 3d space which is created in
the memory game container because
otherwise the memory card is gonna keep
being flat sitting on the 2d plane so
back in the editor let's add those
properties 1000 pixel perspective to
memory gain and transform style
preserved 3d to the memory card
we still don't see that with the effect
because we have to add a transition to
the transform property
and there we have it the 3d effect well
when we flip the card we should be
seeing the front face right and right
now what we are seeing is the inverted J
s badge that happens because every HTML
element has a back face which is a
mirrored image of itself okay
there's also properly called back face
visibility that defaults to visible and
this is why we are seeing the inverted
badge so the first thing you have to do
is to hide the back face
another it's hidden we have to rotate
the front face 180 degrees in the y-axis
so you can see it
you
so when the player clicks a card we have
to know if it's the first or the second
card that he clicks so we can perform
the matching logic
okay so let's declare a variable called
has flipped card and set it to false and
also declare a first and a first card
and second card variables let's update
here toggle to add and we are going to
add a condition okay so if has flipped
card is false this means this is the
first time the player has clicked a card
so then we're gonna set has flipped card
to true and we are gonna set the first
card to the dis keyword remember that
this the element that has fired the
event so in this case is our memory card
so let's console.log both variables
so we can see we have the card we
clicked and has flipped card is now true
and when we click again on other cards
it does not enter the condition because
has flipped card is not true so if has
flipped card is set to false
it means the player is clicking at the
first card if it is set to true it means
the player is clicking in the second
card and it's gonna fall inside the else
clause so we are gonna set has flipped
card back to false and we are gonna set
the second card variable to this and
let's console.log those
okay so it fires only at the second
click and we can see we have the both
cards we just clicked
so now that we have both cards which
just clicked we have to check if those
cards match and how we're gonna do that
so we're gonna make use of a very handy
attribute in HTML which is the data
attribute with that you can add to your
elements any kind of information you
want okay you can call it also whatever
you want you can call it data name you
can call it data image we're gonna call
it data framework and pass the name of
the framework the UM it's holding so
let's add that to every one of our
memory cards
you
in order to access the data attribute
that you defined in your HTML we do this
through the data set object okay so it
goes your element dot data set dot the
name you have chosen
you
now that we can identify our cards we
have to check if the data set dot
framework from the first card and the
second card are the same if they are we
are going to remove the event listener
from the cards to prevent them from
being clicked again and if it's not we
are gonna then I'll flip the cards back
to the original state okay so let's add
that condition and if it's a match we
disable the event listener with remove
event listener so it works you have to
add the event and the function your code
to make sure they have been removed
let's add a blog message here
all right they were correctly executed
and then when we click again it won't
fire because it's not going to the
function anymore
and then if it's not a match we won't
flip the cards to do that we are going
to remove the flip class from the card
you
okay so the second card hasn't turned so
when we clicked the card it has
immediately removed the flipped class so
we don't even we cannot even see it
being flipped what we have to do is to
add a set timeout with a 1500 second
delay so there's enough time available
for us to see the flipping
right now we have a bunch of nested
conditions inside our code and that
makes our method very hard to read so
let's make some refactoring here and
first of all we are going to extract the
matching logic to its own own method and
we are going to call it check for match
the code inside the he fails blocks are
also going to be extracted to their own
methods in case it is a match we're
gonna call disable cards and in case
it's not we're gonna call I'll flip
cards
now that we have just one statement
being executed inside our if/else block
there's an even shorter way we can write
this by using a ternary operator so a
ternary operator has three blocks the
first one we place our condition the
second one is the statement to be
executed if the condition evaluates to
true and a third one if the condition
evaluates to false all right so a
ternary operator allows you to write an
if/else block in just one line
and up here we can switch the else
clause for a return statement in the end
of our if cuz if the condition evaluates
to true the return statement is gonna
stop the function execution there and in
case it's not true the code executed
it's the one that would be inside the
else clause so this makes the condition
a bit cleaner
you
right now our games a bit buggy because
there are some corner cases we have to
take care of one of them is if we try to
flip a second set of cards before the
first set have finished and flipping
then that crashes our logic so in case
it's not a match we have to lock the
board and wait until the cards finish on
flipping so let's declare a lock board
variable and set it to false and the
first statements are inside our flip
card function will be to return from the
function if lock board is true so the
rest won't get executed in case is not a
match we are going to lock the board and
not only unlock it after cards have been
flipped
the second corner case we have to pay
attention to is if we click twice over
in the same card because in that case is
a match is gonna runway to true and it's
going to disable the cards by removing
its event listener so the card is going
to remain flipped we have to add a
condition to the beginning of our flip
card function to avoid that so if it is
the first card click then the disable
holds the first card but the first card
variable is still on set so that
conditions going to evaluate to false
and the function will be executed
normally if it is the second card click
then the disable holds the second card
and in case that equals first card then
it will return from the function
in order for our condition to work after
each round we have to set first card a
second card to know so let's extract
that to to a method of its own called
reset board and they're gonna set has
flipped card and lock board false and
first and second cardinal and we can do
this using the es6 destructuring
assignment which keeps our code very
very short
you
the last thing left first to do in our
game is to shuffle our cards we are
gonna do this with a flexbox properly
called order that's a flex items
property and need the force to zero
which means that every flex item belongs
to the same group and then they will be
grouped by source order if you assign a
different integer to the order property
items will get ordered first by
ascending order according to the value
in the order properly and then they will
get ordered by source order so to
shuffle our deck of cards we are going
to generate a random number between 0
and 11 and assign to each one of our
cards
let's start iterating through our deck
of cards and to generate our random
number
we are going to use the math dot random
function which returns us a random
number between 0 & 1 excluding 1 since
we want a number that goes from 0 to 11
we are going to multiply that number by
12 and since the order property needs an
integer we have to apply math dot floor
in order to get that so now that we have
our random number we can apply it to the
order properly
we need our deck of cards to be shuffled
before the player starts the game so
instead of calling the shuffle function
as we normally would
let's wrap it inside a parenthesis and
net next repair of parenthesis to the
end of it and that makes that function
into an immediately invoked function
expression which means that that
function will be executed right after
its definition
and that's it for our memory game
tutorial I hope you have enjoyed it
please subscribe to the channel so you
get our updates ok see ya